yeah hello welcome to this video this is
the final round of the same field cup
let's see what happened in this decisive
round before they wrong we had to live
on aronian leading the event by one
point ahead of a couple of other players
I think for I a so there was the very
theoretical possibility that Aronian
would lose his game and one of the
others would win so it could be a time
um I decide I was thinking a little bit
um how to cover that fine around him and
what order of games I should choose
because there was one game that was
clearly the most interesting of that
round and it wasn't related to the top
standings that much um yeah a little bit
but it didn't affect first place let's
say so I'm doing it a little bit
different and I'm starting with the game
that clarifies the whole thing um and it
was to pull off with white against
aronia yeah we got Queens gambit
declined with Bishop before the Rope
goes in variation nowadays very popular
a popular top level chairs I'm also one
of our own Ian's main defenses yeah to
part of when Bishop g5 and now aronian a
bit surprisingly captured on c4 this is
a main continuation of course but it's
not something that he has played that
often on the main line of white is e 4
and then c5 Bishop c4 when we get line
that is normally called the Vienna
variation it is some frequently reached
by this move this but shouldn't be for
Bishop g5 it's the same position um but
to pull off didn't do that which is
again surprising he went Jayne a for
check knight c6 and a 3 yeah this is a
pawn sacrifice she goes after the
capture which is virtually forced
otherwise why would get the pawn
without any problems now black plays
Queen d5 somewhat strange looking for
putting the Queen in the middle of the
board but well it covers that pawn and
it has an eye on that bishop so it's a
little bit uncomfortable for wide to
face you really want to develop your
King side but how exactly are you going
to do it if you play let's say like g3
then 94 it's more than annoying yeah
looking at this looking at this and if
you go bishop d 292 I mean this is this
is a joke right white it's a bit
difficult so wyd basically had to take
them and now 92 to get the idea of f4
introduced and maybe getting that porn
back now I ever be five yeah and black
keeps the pawn to Palo went back a 6 e
four and they continued with relatively
normal looking moves g3 should be seven
Bishop tutu 97 yeah that makes lots of
sense that looks to open up the diagonal
and possibly go f5 at the right moment
note that the polyp had played this
relatively quickly the first couple of
moves so it was part of his preparation
let's take stop here why does a pawn
down here sacrifice a pawn um what is
this compensation mmm it's not that
clear actually I mean he's saying that
he's getting a good center d 484 but
black has both c5 and f5 as ways to
attack the center and if those center
pawns have to move somehow give up their
ideal tandem on d4 you for then yeah
that's not that great I think this whole
approach is is rather fishy let's say I
mean black doesn't have any problem
really and roped in one group d8e form
c5 later in the interview uronian said
that he felt it was a relatively easy
game for him
because blacks play was so obvious which
is kind of true because well what else
do you have you want to attack the
center with c5 possibly f5 this is what
he did the only question really in this
whole thing is like about him to pile of
wet Knight f3 if black has some way to
really get more out of this because I
think it's really questionable that why
just got on something greater for his
porn I mean he's got some activity
that's true but maybe there is a way for
black 22 to do more one thing is that
some taking into account the tournament
standings aronian always knew that with
the draw he would have he would win the
event and this is an important thing to
remember even though everybody wants to
win a game if you have on the
opportunity to seal the event with a
draw you're pretty much if you would
draw differently than just any kind of
draw in the first round um and this
becomes some important a little bit
later again f5 was played and now after
this two part of you gain that pawn
however i'm black now of course crashes
through in the center with Bishop takes
Bishop takes and seat XD first glance it
looks really good for black right
because if wide would recapture then is
running into a super fork here right now
and warm he only has a check King here
Quincy three and then f6 attacks this
this is under fire it's pretty awful
yeah black black still has that pawn
right um white cannot recapture but he
has a good move he has Quincy one and
here's that then moment that i mentioned
we're under different circumstances
maybe black can do something different
and then what he did he played the move
d take c3 which basically ends the game
as wide now is forced to take on fi
with that rook and give a perpetual
check we can look at this first hood so
that you understand what what I'm what
I'm referring to chapter you'd read it
here takes and now check chances
dimensional perpetual means that detects
see is really this move is forcing the
draw like as forcing the draw here what
what is it that he could have done it
could have played either King age eight
or Queenie seven Queenie seven is
looking at that square here and to make
sure that the queen is not showing up
them and here black has some chances
maybe to play for win it is not entirely
entirely clear if how good it is what
can try walk before Bishop a form which
will be force may be the better tribe
simply trying to take hear something
like this for example it's something
that black can try to play for win
however I mean we see that his King
position is rather shaky you can also
imagine black somehow screwing this up
if he is doing something something
stupid so it's understandable yeah you
have the tournament win with the draw so
you go for it this is just good
pragmatism by aronia and yeah comrades
to him he has played a good event three
wins against the American players and
six drawers no loss really really good
event after a long period of rather
uninspiring tournaments okay let's look
at the other games we have mvl versus
arnesh Geary Geary plate them the Neo
arc arch angels I think the name of it
bit of a strange opening name um yeah a
pretty good line actually for black it's
one of the more active defenses in the
room
I'm comparing to those where you play
Bishop e7 it demands a little bit more
knowledge of concrete lines if wise
plays in a sharp way which most geograph
now did not do in play them relatively
solid line here with mostly developing
what can also play with a quick a 4
which is much sharper so all this looks
very normal and now rupee 8 was played
an interesting little tactic that always
has to be mentioned in this in this kind
of this opening is that black if we look
at this black very often cannot take
because of this tactic it's an important
tactic to remember it happens rather
frequently the Royal opus yeah that
black defenses youporn technically like
that and wins apiece him on exchange and
like root x III um rupee aid was played
however they eat XD for by the way it's
not a bad move it's just that black
hands to play differently after that
rugby AIDS yeah III giving the bishop
that's where to stay on that diagonal
and now give it to Gandhi form um so me
c5 looks a little bit more logical let's
say but of course his movies is ok em I
would probably rather go see if I but
this is probably due to my history of
playing the Chi goring and always want
to use the C pawn it don't like it so
much to take on deform and however as I
said it's um it's interesting yeah
Bishop takes now and again see takes was
also possible 94 and now here maybe even
bishop age six a line which is a bit
strange I mean Black has one issue here
a little bit he's got two pieces on b6
and a5 that has somewhat offside
and blacks king site is a little bit
deserted so I'm not sure how comfortably
is to allow that that Bishop takes h6 it
can be a little bit tricky well Bishop
deformers played anyway and 96 now take
stakes and now see for attacking that b5
porn yeah give me now when to be four
which is I'm not sure I mean maybe it is
a bit risky in fact and it wasn't
completely necessary black still could
have played on a development moves like
and I can probably push owe me six out
but should be 37 looks bit passive and
you want to put that Bishop out the
thing is why I'm not so sure about
before is that everybody else replies c5
now um I think looks a bit tricky for
black to handle yeah he has to take
essentially otherwise I mean if you just
go back you would get this this
structure that's a bit awkward it's not
terrible but looks awkward he took it
and now um this poor information gives
might I mean White has pretty good
places for its pieces c4b 3 and the big
thing is that this is happening White
has got four against three on the Kings
side and gains space with that if I move
now the night and has to go somewhere
and wherever you go it doesn't look
super comfortable maybe night age five
would have been more interesting now so
have this night f4 possibility um but
give you went to age seven and now after
nightly form it looks really active for
wide however however I don't think it's
it's terrible for black it just seems a
bit difficult to play but give me I
think plays it really really well now
like this be three NC form and while
that looks a bit awkward to me White has
a nice night there on c3 possibly now we
see we see some other
night here night back here I mean what
whites position looks good but how do
you really really do something
substantial here it looks it seems
difficult now you cannot really put more
pressure on those pawns here and black
seems to be solid yeah gary is defending
this very tenacious Lee even this year
that looks really strange they're
putting that rook on the edge of the
board but it is the correct decision the
rook is doing something I'd put pressure
here and limits a white speed system
night has to retreat and I went g5 here
maybe not FG six was even even somewhat
better for black it's possible because f
was not not in the position here and
white has to yeah take care of the pawn
some other way probably ninety six now
on either three bosses both as possible
something like this here for example and
not be sure to five you have to make
sure that the rook is not taking him
yeah and well Black is upon up yep slope
which should be six maybe and don't I
think your black has may be slight
chances to do something I mean why it is
very very active and those pawns are not
super strong so there are still a very
definite chances of this game ending in
a draw but here it seems that there's
more giri use doing something yeah g5
bishop a 396 and the way it went went
here and there was really no way for
black to do something they m continued
here with this sequence black was
returning that porn but he retains a
rather active position now with the rook
to be eight other look would activate
himself here and now this double rook
endgame is those those those end games
are very often rather draw edge because
if both sides are very active it often
leads
both sides just taking pawns bonds bonds
and at some point it'll be a bit
simplified to just nothing happening
here white looks to have the better plan
structure but well what is it worth your
black ass trading of everything here
they agreed to a draw so I'm rather
correct draw there in that game maybe
gear we actually had had a little
something when when he played with when
you Bethenny I played in a g6 it's
really it's possible it's really
possible okay so let's look at the next
game let's do an on Carlton right I
should have done that before actually
and to take make take the two were
champions first okay so we go to Berlin
not super exciting but yeah this is how
it is nowadays sometimes and we got the
endgame can with h5 yeah that is some
the mainline are nowadays form black and
the to be perfectly honest I mean I'm
not next but not at all but when I a
couple of weeks ago I think it was
somewhere in the summer early summer in
June or something I took took a couple
of hours to look through the the Berlin
endgame it's really just nothing
provider it really seems like nothing at
least for my um my chance understanding
it feels like it is nothing going on and
this game is pretty much yeah further
confirmation of that they took a while
to reach that position for us for some
reason but it has been played before
know that term not black has the two
bishops and the the main issue really is
what will happen quite often is what
exactly happened in the game Black has
two bishops and this Bishop here will
very often trade itself against the
night and then we have opposite color to
ship
and this is just the dead dead draw I
mean and look what happened and then
Bishop d7 G for Luke t8 kingi to run
again getting out of this group takes 24
IDM if Y place and non move then I can
consider to take here and this is this
is already a draw yeah King g2 and here
yeah and what now why 23 can you when
you if your if you move that night then
you're playing for a loss very clearly
so see three txt stakes and now we got
the opposite colored bishops end game
and it is really a total draw I mean
it's so we'll fix it such it's so George
that it doesn t take a very strong
player now form for either side to make
that draw yeah black is losing that c7
pawn but it doesn't really matter here
they agree to a draw and the way how
this is drawn is actually I'm pretty
young pretty typical how you draw
opposite color to bishops end games of
pong down and it's quite funny that
still the engine gives so had an
advantage well no ya well what what is
what exactly is the principle to draw
that and it's pretty simple very often
you have a situation that can be divided
between Queen silent Kings side one side
of the board usually the bishop will
hold yeah with some kind of fortress and
the other side the king will hold so how
does black actually keep that or make
that draw here yeah this this
configuration here on the queenside we
see pretty clearly that black putting
him that was a wrong wrong arrow putting
the bishop here would protect c6 which
in turn protects the pawn so this is a
perfect fortress situation this is the
Queen side this is easily dealt with
with the bishop and how does black keep
it on the King side that's pretty simple
he just stays yeah just does nothing
stays with the King and waits until
white gets some kind of pass oh yeah we
can let's do it them in a very simple
way like this and now we are blocking on
a light square we can block on g6 we can
block on g8 it doesn't matter and here
the next blacks moves are just always
bishop d5 to h1 and back and back and
back and forth and back and forth and
it's dead now the other way sometimes to
draw us if we M go back here into the
actual position in the game you black
also can do something that will also
draw again you can drop another pawn
that's also possible why it takes and
then you go here now you are two points
down it still doesn't matter the king
will stay on f7 blocking the two pawns
it's light squared so there's no check
there's no way to get it get it away
from the board um and well nothing
happens wyd can can shuffle whatever I'm
f4 and again I'm doing this yeah the
Queen side is completely safe nothing
happens and the King blocks the pawns
this is the typical procedure to draw
those end games you have to find a good
distribution of roads between King and
Bishop one side has to be kept by the
bishop one by the king okay that was a
rather lengthy explanation of that
rather boring position but it done maybe
was helpful to get an idea how those
opposite colored bishops and games are
often drawn you have to really find a
set up there I am 11 for the king one
for the bishop ok so whats next game
kind of confusing myself a little it
would be kawana versus restless so
notes on that here yeah so here we go we
got a got an English opening here
English double fianchetto yeah it's a
very solid line for black and what I
wanna is doing is he plays the main line
nowadays with Queen age form and the
later g4 that's an interesting way to
play rook e8 Bishop here here and now g4
to be perfectly honest I've played this
kind of opening with white form half of
my chest career maybe more and then
never really fully understood what this
g4 and wish of a 3g for business is
doing I think 11 idea of that somewhat
strange setup is that it disrupts blacks
coordination a lot but yeah if that
night has to move then this Bishop only
seven sometimes really just taking there
and then be six my four it's a very
weird very weird way of combining play
on the kingside to achieve things on the
queenside on this is at least my my take
on it and the next move that that so is
playing is a bit is a bit term
questionable it seems Queen a8 yeah when
when tu t'appelle office was asked about
this he said that he felt that this was
a mistake and it was what what did you
say basically basically losing it sounds
harsh but yeah black seems to be in
trouble after that maybe it was a better
idea to to keep the Queen there another
way of playing this is also bishop aah
yeah this is what kayak ended in some
recent games okay but let's have a look
what happened after Korea 8 why was that
so so tricky
this was played by kawana a bishop
deform and I also looked at the move g5
because of a very simple idea if black
goes to e4 which looks like the idea of
Queen ADA to get that controller then
White has 94 an interesting idea white
threatens to take on d7 and then only
six the thing is that after this this
window of the exchange yeah oops that
whenever the exchange is not entirely
clear if you look at this position for a
bit and you recognize that black has a
really strong bishop on b7 and white
skin it's a bit shaky this is not a
totally clear position for instance the
engine just gives white 0.2 something
very very miniscule so it seems to be
perfectly playable for black I mean it's
not just that the engine says that when
you see that Bishop on b7 I'd only for
the bishops are strong there is Knight
c3 as an as an opportunity at some
moment yeah it's clear that black has
some play for that exchange um this is
what can one up late and it led to a
good position for why it seems it's a
it's a difficult position to play age 6
is what West they did and now g5 was
played yeah and this is awkward it
really is awkward you now have that
Queen h7 idea always in play and white
threatens various things on or
potentially threatens various things
related to that yeah like taking or d7
they don't have six and then getting
that check in the check itself I mean
it's not checkmate but it's always kind
of hanging over your head this is this
threat um this is what what Wesley is so
played now yeah it's not great yeah but
what
but was it 122 dish what he should have
done very difficult white also has this
95 ideas sometimes that can be awkward
this is probably why you six was played
but after your 6 it's definitely very
problematic for black that part is weak
and it's not clear how it should be
defended he tried the queen bee eight
now Bishop f5 white immediately takes
this routine c4 that's a needler tactic
that's very important this is what was
played and this is a much stronger move
yeah and now the next move was Bishop f8
and it seems that this is almost losing
the game d5 was necessary even though it
looks terrible I mean this is the move
you really don't want to play I
understand perfectly ym y so I didn't
didn't want to play that it looks
strategically terrible gives away d5
opens up that diagonal and so on but
after here now if Kara wanna plays the
right move it's just over well but he
didn't he didn't he took on d6 with the
rook which looks very attractive but it
is not as good as it looks yeah it's a
kind of flashy this move but it's not as
effective what he could have done is he
could have taken with the bishop simply
netting their pawn the important thing
is that that rook takes you four is not
working now to turn to a nice low tech
deck yeah and here I have haven't done
that for a while but in this position if
you want you can look for a tactic I'll
show it in a couple of seconds where
white no wins with this check nice move
one h8 champs oops and everything hangs
nothing's very very nice what already is
a pawn up but there's tons of stuff
hanging it will win the second point is
six like rupee eight and here internets
over yeah very nice so but should be six
wheels what
it really is a winning position and well
you have to see that right here I mean
if flag does not have lube takes c4 what
is his move yeah I mean something like
that right is piling up and he still has
a big attack and with the Queen Nia has
got a 45 coming and Bishop sacrifices
are looming a terrible yeah brooke t6
was played why was that so why wasn't
that good the thing is that well this is
good for white yeah because he will
always get this back and yes maybe
sometimes opportunities to even not
recapture the exchange the problem is
this movie 5 and all of a sudden this
hangs and well and the room hangs as
well force so this is a narrow rather
messy it really is he took on d7 and
then black took here yeah it's there
that has this has to be played Knight
takes as major checkmate and you rook
takes Bishop takes is also winning
forward so this has to be played but now
look at this now here Bishop g7 their
King g7 was a bit stronger but if we
look at this distance now I'm white
being a pawn up but it is a rather messy
position and the other continuation was
just so clear and with Bishop takes t6
ok this was played and now Luke back to
the three here it seems that can one
head and john sruthi six was a stronger
move looking to take that pawn that
second porn and dumb the idea is to
block that diagonal so if black moves
here then we can take that pawn can take
that pawn later yeah all 94 that's also
an interesting moves in this position it
is still very complicated yet if white
takes here for example Queenie 5 turns
out to be rather tricky and this Hanks
this is under pressure and that rook is
loose
yeah for example like here group t3
night h5 and all kinds of messy things
are happening it's really really weird
this was played and now after movie 7 it
seems that black is fairly okay yeah
White's King is also not feeling so
comfortable and well I mean white is a
pawn up but you're miles away from
entering a technical game this is often
important to understand sometimes one
side is its material up a pawn up mostly
but you're not getting to a situation
where you can really slowly build up on
your position or can do little
improvement move so that you
automatically can convert a pawn in some
kind of endgame it is just a position
that cannot easily be simplified and
this is the case here likes pieces are
now all active and I mean you're not
simply just pushing the queenside home
now that that doesn't happen yeah you
have to look at many other things going
on on the board and then the further
cause of the action yeah we got this
here plug got to take on e2 but white it
install this nice knight on d5 it seems
however that black OS has enough player
you close the queenside them and the
difficult thing is try to find a way
forward yeah that knight on d5 it looks
nice but it has nowhere to go it's quite
a funny situation yeah it cannot go
everywhere anywhere on the board and
that means as long as that night is
staying with other rooks on the Defiler
also not very effective you have a very
strange situation where both sides don't
cannot make much progress they either
shuffled lot back and forth and
somewhere here agree to it wrong check
here here they agree to a draw it is
some it's really it's a strange kind of
draw it's a little bit like a positional
draw and in a way in us as it's
sometimes called because neither side
can make any any progress and the knight
on d5 is kind of in a way dominated in
this position and the same time at the
same time black cannot do anything
either yeah I mean this is playing for
loss so so a draw I mean definitely
kawana had excellent chances to win that
game he just he just had to take on
these six or was it was a messy position
so it's not like he's played like
terribly bad or anything it is just that
that was a clear clear on spot where
that the right move probably would have
won him the game without any any further
problems okay so let's look at nakamura
gris shock in that final round as a
final game for that event that was the
most interesting game of that round
let's have a look check yeah again the
Bishop b5 check light and again 97's is
chosen I really wonder why they don't
play Bishop e7 that much I mean I
understand if they go 97 that's usually
signaling the intention to play an
active aggressive whatever but we should
be seven has some very M solid
reputation but nobody seems to play it I
mean after Bishop d7 you very awesome
get that the Roxy kind of structure
maybe people are really not so keen on
that anymore it was always thought that
this type of maroc see with one pair of
pieces exchange should be quite okay for
black I mean understand that people like
the white side i also do but objectively
speaking it shouldn't be that terrible
for blankets it's just surprising that
nobody plays it in that event they all
go 97 okay castles
this seems to be more popular nowadays
ng4 which is the traditional main
continuation here okay castles um a six
and Bishop e3 the same setup as a in the
earlier carlton to pile of game the
difference is that he and early c3 is
played and now White has that C 2 square
for a special that looks a quite quite
nice for white quite natural so Bishop
be some rookie one rook c8 fo yeah very
normal looking play yet default also
looks normal but after Teague's and pawn
takes Queen c7 as possible yeah this is
a bit awkward now what are you doing if
you move your bishop black has this
funny opportunity yeah night-night years
entirely wrong rookie too it's also not
better so you cannot go d 4 I mean you
can but you really only want to do it if
you can take with the pawn yeah this was
played before a5 all normal stuff and
now III again d 4 was not possible due
to that C file pressure Kings takes andy
sixx I think all that looks fairly
fairly normal and Ti well there's this
position I mean it cannot be anything
brilliant for four white it looks rather
um yeah it doesn't look very aggressive
at first sight however this kind of
setup that white went for here has one
practical advantage it totally avoids
any simplifications this is a very very
interesting aspect that is often
underestimated when people talk about
opening results yeah quite often people
want to yeah I want some edges the idea
with why do I want to have pressure and
so on
and this is sometimes difficult to
achieve especially when people think
that they should play a total main lines
and everything well if you play into a
main line let's sell the night off you
might have a 25 move string or
theoretical on 25 a move string of
theoretical things and I at the end
there is some kind of Perpetual yeah
this is sharp all cool but it's still a
totally boring draw without any single
move played over the board this is what
sometimes happens in the so called sharp
openings when you play in such a
restrained approach and this is the idea
that Nakamura head here he didn't want
to play a boring draw he wanted to keep
everything on the board and just delay
the fight until later this is exactly
what we got in this game and typical
this is in fact a modern approach yeah
it sounds them it sounds on I don't know
I mean this kind of opening set up
doesn't seem very modern but it's just
the approach that very often nowadays is
the right one you don't want any heavy
theoretical discussion just want to have
a game played very often you want the
game to be most interesting getting it's
it's it's it's tough spots later when
time is ticking down and so on it also
probably a good idea against Christian
Gary already see that Nakamura didn't
spend much time here but we show here
Hans was burning time for rather normal
moves as usual yeah but should be five
and now 9ft to keeping everything yeah
as it is white also had the movie 5 that
was interesting but it's not clear that
it Nets wide so much we probably would
have had some some simplifications there
yeah an interesting line is night xe5
net fe5 night d5 very strange movements
it seems to be okay for black takes
takes yeah and now we should takes Queen
d8 is really not much going on yeah but
92 white wanted to keep everything on
the board route 28
push your back yeah slow slow playing
just delaying the file and note that
Grisha is burning time now he's taking
minutes and minutes and minutes over
relatively yeah uncritical looking moves
that same avoiding the draw yeah no no
draw my camera I wanted to win that game
yeah again five minutes spent and now f4
yeah this is this is the way what did I
describe him now we both play as a
somewhat down on time and we show gets
down to 15 minutes there's no increment
yes to move its playable 14 News now in
15 minutes this is still not a huge time
scramble but it makes things more
difficult and if you get something going
it will be it will be tougher to defend
with that time ticking down yeah this is
not a bad porn structure for what it
gives it entails some risk but it also
gives a good central control those
doubled pawns 9th back to d1 g6 I mean
black should be okay here don't get me
wrong but it will be difficult in a
practical game this is what I'm getting
at we should back to age 29 h 523
keeping f4 protected yeah keep that back
yeah I think this is phase of the game
is pretty straightforward if I gaining
that space and gaining access to two
squares 097 well that's that all looks
very very logical other night might come
here so nakamura prevented that with
chief or um there one critical moment
comes here f5 txtx night f2 and this
position is probably
equal ish yeah let's say I mean I want
to say that no side has a clear edge in
this position but it's of course not
boring and it's not like nothing is
happening um and I think now with them
yell at I'm getting low and we shook is
some playing something something strange
I think he was probably very much afraid
of the night coming to e4 and so we
decided to play Bishop age four and I am
taking that night and I don't really
like that decision I mean I'm a huge fan
of the bishop pair but this is not the
reason for that I mean every good
players slacking his bishop pair but the
thing is that also the dark squares are
weakened quite a bit by that procedure
and after that it seems that is right
who's definitely calling calling the
shots while the situation without that
Bishop age for most was as I said rather
unclear let's say complicated and
difficult to to call so I think that
that feels very logical 28 yeah and now
Nakamura is going for it on h4 yeah you
have to do something if you want to
Whitney I mean why doesn't a position
that's important to understand why does
in a position now after that that Bishop
was given up 1 F 2 when he also could
have just could've just said in wait
yeah there was nothing white is just
shuffling here black has nothing to do
right I mean white has those pressure
here on that porn and black is just
sitting there cannot do much but h4 kept
getting something going Luke f82 King h
eight and now interesting moves look we
want the idea is that rook b6 is an idea
now the idea is that this is an idea
that's a weird sentence but it
introduces this route b6 idea
and it basically provoked black to
capture which is what group did he took
that pond and now h5 here we go no the
idea is that this is a checked Black has
to take essentially and now f5 f5 it's
dangerous it gets really really
dangerous Tigs takes has to be done and
now Queen d8 was played and it seems
after that white has a fantastic
position probably a winning position 98
what was the much tougher defense it is
it is very difficult to play this
position this is what is important to
understand even though um maybe um
objectively here white is not winning or
even super clearly better it's difficult
to play and this is all yeah a little
bit due to that Bishop takes f2 decision
that was William handing white some some
easier play and this one would be one
was a strong idea provoking Queen a five
so 98 how it does it continue look we
ate probably that looks good looking at
taking this and now black can jettison
one pawn he has to do that and now do
this and here White has strong pressure
for his pawn but it's not totally a
parent um how he how he should win this
yeah I mean maybe maybe you can if you
invest lots of time with with an engine
you can try to figure out if white can
win I mean he definitely has as I said
you'd pressure but is it a win I mean
the computers don't think so if you'll
give it like a minute or so but it looks
it looks tricky it looks really tricky
to play I mean there's the G file and
there are various ideas to strengthen
the position yeah I rook c8 something
like this
sound Luke g2 yeah i mean it's it's
absolutely uncomfortable to play for
black but i'm not totally sure if if it
is a if it is a win or white somehow
after Queen d8 however it is winning why
definitely wins now f6 that's good a 98
yeah black cannot take check now this is
the point note that White's King has no
port cover but it's safe and there is
this mating threat now the only thing
that black and do is king g8 and now
change Queen takes Queen g7 this oops
come on check this is forced and will
win for white this is why 98 had to be
played no no other choice Bishop age
form very nicer or pieces participate
this this route g8 this is the best
defense also and here in this position
it turns out that there was only just
one move I mean I saw part of this from
here I saw part of the broadcast here
there was only one move one move that
decides the game and that was rook g1 I
was really strong root g one the idea is
that if black takes it and it's
difficult not to if that takes it here
um black really has no move to defend
there is a big threat here Bishop takes
h7 now Bishop h7 rook h7 queen of eight
mate and if black moves that night to
get some control over f8y twins which is
cute move check check it's amazing after
this year black really has no defenses
absolutely nothing
to save him yeah let's save any move
white cheeks and that computer even
shows a force made and something made at
seven or so yeah but Nakamura didn't
play that if they'd look II one that
also looks good the idea is to play
rookie seven it's rather logical and
it's not like it's completely out of
this world we should never forget that
if black takes him chat and this is just
winning this this is my eighth and Queen
Jake's of course will take the Queen
yeah not much to do but d5 this move is
still possible Luke t6 check as sorry
Queen d6 check is a sudden resource that
probably Nakamura had missed or under
under estimated rookie six now was
interesting but he took on h5 human
decision take that pawn check rookie 5d
for now it took on d4 it seems that your
Bishop g3 wasn't strong move but the
lines that are connected with that are
really just to be at night f6 Queen f7
94 jay king g one with age 6 whatever
your position ur made then white jackin
can give that back chat until white is
better but that line is just too weird
to play for a human being he took on d4
community eggs and rookie 7 it seems
that black really is back in this game
and there was one particular moment
right here check here here when we
should probably could have heard that
but well you know one minute something
this is the problem this position is
super difficult and
is basically a maneuvering a minefield
him and Bishop d7 is what he played
after that he seems to be lost again 26
seems to be a draw unfortunately okie
dokie didn't do that Bishop f5 Queen III
should direct draw yeah that's up oh
sorry that's a perpetual and queen f5
there was root g 6 and it's not it's not
apparent how white should win it's
really not really strange but it seems
that black is may be awarding this ok
this was played Bishop f5 and now the
problem is check this was played but
what else is there if Chad takes Queen
takes um White's king is safe and well
what can try to just just strengthen the
position from here like a queen d 5 for
example is a pretty pretty good
continuation and asking black about this
do we want to take care really yeah he
tried this this is what we shall played
that looks funny but after you get three
it doesn't really help check check we
now get this position and this is just
dead lost it really is dead lost because
of that e seven pawn it is just too
strong teen g7 Bishop d3 check black has
to go back here you can never go here
because of this we get something similar
in the check here in the game and now
now this is this part of the game I mean
black is completely paralyzed and white
is winning but now camera is playing
that part of the game in a really really
strong fashion Bishop f4 with little
time and I mean that also always has to
be taken into account Bishop f4 man a
five black place h5 white is coming up
the king yeah just this and now we are
threatening we should be five Andrew
gave seven weed seeds we see this exact
same thing later in the game a five and
now Bishop age six a form goes back III
grabs it a two Bishop before control
what's this yeah and now what now 97
Bishop a 198 c5 c6 night back King um
yeah and here we shook resigned very
nice very nice finish by a binder camera
black isn't a complete zoosk one if he
takes on c7 then ruka seven is just
winning the house the combination of the
bishop rook and King do the job yeah
very nice finish of that game it was a
true fight yeah I mean both sides really
did put up a great fighting job and that
camera won that game i think deservedly
so because he really tried to do
everything to win it was a um something
that had had to do much with the will to
win and and it did it paid off in that
game yeah this is the end of the courage
for the sink filled cup it was an
interesting event with a convincing
winner with levon aronian and really he
ended a long time stretch of
unsuccessful events with that with that
win are you enjoy hope you enjoyed the
coverage I'm not quite sure what I will
cover next what top level event there is
the world cup but the world cup is
always tricky to cover because they have
so many games um maybe I'll pick the odd
game if there's something really
standing out but I have not really made
up our mind yet about that okay thanks
for watching guys bye